this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you very much Alejandra it's great
to be here in the in the frozen north
so this today's talk is going to be in
two parts and the first part is about
the topic that's in the title and the
second part is is related to that but
it's really about recent research that
project that I've started working on
with Richard Barclay who's somebody who
did a postdoc with me and has stayed on
at the Smithsonian to to do this work
and it's I think you'll see how they're
related so I hope it doesn't come across
as as too disjointed things because they
they really are pretty firmly connected
mmm so this is a common graph that a lot
of people see in an intro geology class
or earth history class and it's
basically the temperature history of the
last 65 million years or so as
reconstructed from oxygen isotope
measurements of forums collected mostly
through deep sea Corrine programs and
this is I give popular talks so I
converted this temperature scale to
Fahrenheit and then it confuses me when
I'm not but I won't apologize for that
we'll just go right ahead here's here's
global mean temperature today more or
less and this is this temperature record
and of course the first thing that pops
out at anybody is that most of the last
65 million years have been a lot warmer
than today were in the middle of a
period of glacial interglacial
fluctuations and we also of course are
in a period of rapid global warming so
trying one thing that Earth historians
can do and the paleobotanist can do is
try to to develop a better and
standing of the warm climates of the
past as a way of trying to help
understand what might be happening in
the future
and a lot of my research in the last 25
years has focused on a particular very
short interval of time so this is this
spike here is an event called the
paleocene-eocene thermal maximum I'm
always curious like how many people in
this room have heard of the
paleocene-eocene thermal maximum so you
know some but but not all depends during
a geology department everybody's heard
of the aliasing Eocene thermal maximum
and doesn't want to hear any more about
it because they if they feel like it's
been overexposed or something so it's
nice to see that that this audience is a
little more mixed in that way so the the
defining features of this of this very
short-term warming event are that we see
a global excursion as it's called in the
in the ratio of carbon-12 carbon-13 and
we see that in in these little 4m shells
from the bottom of the ocean we see it
in organic matter in terrestrial
fossil soils we see it in the teeth of
fossil mammals it's we see it in soil
nodules so it's been picked up around
the planet and it's a rather major
change considering that it's global of
about 3 to 5 per mil so there's there is
this event that that is one indication
of a rather rapid release of a lot of
carbon into the ocean atmosphere system
and because it shows up in so many
different places in from the deep sea to
the to the middle of continents it's
obviously it's obvious that this carbon
release has been mixed by the atmosphere
in the ocean at the
same time there's global warming and
it's was first detected in the oxygen
isotope composition of these same kind
of little forums here and the global
warming is about 5 to 8 degrees Celsius
it seems to be about the same amount of
warming from all the way from the poles
to the equator so it doesn't look as if
the warming is happening locally or
regionally it's really truly global
warming and of course that kind of
warming is consistent with a big release
of carbon at the same time the third
point here there's extensive dissolution
of carbonate in the marine realm so
particularly in the in the deep marine
at the bottom of the ocean there's a
clay interval a period of time during
which deep sea sediments are are
basically don't have any carbonate in
them at all that carbonate dissolution
event is another thing that's consistent
with the release of a lot of carbon
because you would expect that to to
increase the solubility of carbonate in
seawater
and so you should get a a dissolution
interval if there was a big carbon
release this event lasted about 200,000
years and because of the warming and the
changes in ocean chemistry it's
generally thought this is about the best
analog we have in the geologic record
for what humans are doing now so the the
interval has attracted a lot of a lot of
interest from in the geological sciences
you're probably wondering where the
carbon came from because that's the
first question that people ask knowing
that there are no factories to produce
it and the the answer is that that after
25 years of working on the event we
don't we still don't really don't know
where the carbon came from and
increasingly it looks as if the reason
that it's been hard to figure it out is
because it's coming from multiple
reservoirs of carbon and the reservoir
it probably this is a period when
there's a whole lot of volcanic activity
in the North Atlantic the North Atlantic
is rifting open and the sediments that
had been deposited in the North Atlantic
over a period of a hundred million years
were full of organic matter this is
where North Sea oil comes from the
reason why Norway and and Britain are
such major oil-producing nations today
but the bulk volcanism is intruding
seals and dikes into these marine
sediments and probably generating a lot
of carbon dioxide as a consequence it
looks as if at some point the warming
that's the result of this volcano genic
carbon is causing the release of methane
hydrate deposits these are deposits in
the ocean floor that are sort of in an
ice-like state but you this is ice you
can burn and this carbon has an
extremely light isotopic composition so
this shift in carbon isotope composition
that we see that turns out to be a very
useful marker for the event but is also
one of the signs that there's a lot of
carbon being released it's a big change
in the isotopic composition of carbon on
the surface of the earth it's a little
hard to figure out how you could get
such a big change but methane hydrate
deposits are have a composition of
carbon isotope composition of about
minus 60 per mil in the standard Delta
notation and that you know like a land
plant is minus 27 or minus 28 on average
so this very light carbon is being
released at some point probably as a
result of warming that's initiated by
the volcano genic and it's also possible
that there may be carbon coming
from permafrost or from soils as the
result of either oxidation or a wildfire
so it's a complicated event with
probably multiple perhaps sort of
positive feedback loops that are being
generated by warming that initially
comes from from volcanism and this is
just to show the sort of give you a
sense of what the planet looks like at
this time 56 million years ago you have
an Arctic Ocean that's completely open
no no ice there no land ice in the
northern hemisphere and this is where
the rifting is happening there are lots
of flood basalts there and I'm gonna
sort of focus in on this area in Wyoming
in just a minute this is a map giving
you a sense of where we have information
about the this paleocene-eocene thermal
maximum of event on either in shallow
marine sections here and here that
record in Holland diagrams the shift
across the boundary or in a few places
in western North America we have
information that's from outcrops that
are actually exposed and the primary one
is is here in Wyoming in a place called
the Bighorn Basin which is where I've
done most of my work and and that's what
I'm going to talk about today so this is
a very fortuitous thing the mountains
are rising around this inter Montaigne
Basin from starting about probably 63 or
64 million years ago and going right
through the paleocene-eocene interval
and as a result you know these are these
were weathering off at the time and and
streams were coming down into this
subsiding you know Montaigne Basin and
depositing fluvial soils Alivia
sediments which were then being modified
by soil forming processes and the red
stripes you're seeing
here are fossilized soil deposits formed
on those ancient floodplains 56 million
years ago and this very bright red
stripe that you see here is actually the
paleocene-eocene thermal maximum are
part of it and the fact that that stripe
is so thick and so red reflects an
increase in weathering rates on land at
the same time almost certainly in
response to increased temperature and
precipitation in this area so I
mentioned that carbon isotope excursion
in part because not only is it one of
the signals that we had a carbon release
but it's also a very important tool in
correlating from the deep-sea where
we're able to observe changes in in
ocean chemistry and marine systems and
the terrestrial systems that I'm
interested in and want to talk about
today and it also gives us a way of sort
of tracking changes in the carbon cycle
so this is these are results from the
paper that came out a few years ago we
got a opportunity to drill cores in the
Bighorn Basin through this time interval
which is something that's not often done
in continental settings and it gave us
two long records through the
paleocene-eocene thermal maximum at a
place called polecat bench which had
been investigated over many years
looking at the at vertebrate fossils and
also changes in soils and and other
features and what this core allowed us
to do was to sample essentially
centimeter by centimeter up through time
looking at carbonate nodules that form
in these ancient soil horizons and
getting carbon isotope values from them
and they give us this very very sharp
this is just a few meters of sediment
here
a couple of kailia Saul Horizons showing
this rapid rapid increase in decrease in
the carbon isotope composition of the
soil nodules and then a period of
relatively stable but much lower
isotopic composition and then a recovery
interval here whereas the as the carbon
isotope composition of the soil nodules
increases again back toward the level
that it had before the event occurred so
basically this is this is we think
recording the release of this
isotopically very light carbon from the
methane hydrate deposits or other
sources of light carbon and something
that's just to give you a sense of what
that actually looks like in an outcrop
and I realize now this and probably you
haven't spent decades going to the same
place or at least not to this same place
which which I had so it's like for me
this I know what the scale of this is
but there's nobody standing in it so you
don't but this is just a you know this
is each one of these layers here is each
one of these is a fossil soil horizon
and that's just a few meters of sediment
and this is this is the Paleocene here
this is before the isotope excursion the
isotope excursion starts there and by
the time you get up to this soil horizon
you're already in what we call the body
of the carbon isotope excursion so it's
so really really rapid event the
sedimentation rates here are a meter of
sediment represents maybe two or three
thousand years so we're talking about a
very rapid release of carbon and this
has actually been one of the things that
we've been working on pretty hard is
trying to understand just how rapid and
this is from a paper last year where
we've been able to correlate the using
the shape of the carbon isotope
excursion we've been able to correlate
from these terrestrial
this terrestrial core to marine course
through the same time interval that are
that have a cyclic pattern of change in
the iron content of the core and that
cyclic pattern is also seen in the cores
on land and the cyclic pattern is
generated by Milankovitch the cliff city
so we've got basically a metronome that
gives us these 20,000 21,000 year cycles
which are grouped together at a hundred
thousand year cycles that are controlled
by the eccentricity of the Earth's orbit
and you can see those cycles in the
terrestrial realm and you can see them
in the marine realm you can sort of
combine that information and conclude
that this onset event is less than five
thousand years so it's so it's
geologically pretty close to what we
would call instantaneous it's not as
fast as the human addition of carbon to
the atmosphere today is maybe ten times
slower but it's it's still by far the
fastest event of this type we know of in
the geological record so this has just
made the event that much more
interesting to study is to realize that
you know it's not a perfect analogue for
the future but it's it's it looks better
and better as we get to know more about
it the other there's sort of a local
practical significance this is now we're
heavily individual adji here but you can
you can detect as I said you can detect
that that carbon isotope excursion in
these soil nodules you can also just
grind up a piece of rock and get the
isotopic composition of the dispersed
organic material in that rock because
these are paleo Sol's and when you do
that you can find this carbon isotope
excursion lots of places the the
Badlands I showed you there are places
where you know every Hill is actually as
a record of this event somewhere on that
hill if
you know where to find it so the carbon
isotope excursion has something that
we've and this is a panel section across
about 20 miles of bad land topography
where we've been able to locate we're on
a lot of hillsides the carbon isotope
excursion is which means that you can go
out there and start digging holes
looking for plant fossils which is where
my primary research interest is and I
just made a little montage here of of
the process since it may be that some of
you haven't had the the life
transforming experience of collecting
plant fossils I know some people have
but but it's if you know you should be
careful it's kind of like your first you
know just I'll just try heroin just once
it's it's uh it's you know you really
have to be careful about this because if
you do it you might decide that it's so
much fun you just have to keep doing it
so so these are these are badlands so
that the probably the problem is not
that there's no place to look the
problem is you can look anywhere and you
have to figure out where there actually
are plant fossils in the ground but they
don't wear out so everyone you know if
you're a paleontologist everyone says oh
you must go collect dinosaurs no I don't
collect dinosaurs and you know dinosaurs
you might be able to find a dinosaur
because it would be weathering out at
the side of a hill but the kind of plant
fossils I find do not weather out they
just turn to dust so the only way to
really find them is to go dig a hole
with a shovel so your shovel is
basically your eyes and the hills look
different if you look at them for long
enough but I dig a lot of little holes
looking for a place that looks like it
the rock might have preserved organic
matter and then if we find organic
matter you might dig a slightly larger
hole and if there's some indication of
Lee
fossils or other kinds of plant fossils
you might get your friends to come help
you and dig a bigger hole and then you
can end up in a really good spot you can
dig really big holes this is my this is
my proudest accomplishment of my career
because if you know what year to look on
you can see this whole long on Google
Earth from space so I made a structure
briefly that could be seen from space
this is this is a hole that produced
some really nice plant fossils this is
actually in the PETM and once we find
them we use extremely technologically
advanced equipment to bind them up so
they don't fall apart on the trip back
to the museum and then they they go back
and and sit in the dusty collections
areas and get studied by me and other
people who are interested in them so
that's the life cycle of fossils or at
least studying fossils and over a period
of time I've like this record goes from
this is just a piece of the record from
56 point to 255 points so this is a
million years of time and the record
that I've assembled of Flores through
time is goes for another three or four
million years that way and another three
or four millions years this way but this
is the part of it I wanted to focus on
today and each one of these crosses is a
place in the Bighorn Basin where we've
measured a section and we know where we
are in relation to the carbon isotope
excursion so time is running this way
and I just stacked up the localities so
they tend to occur in groupings because
once you find an interval of time where
you have good preservation you often
find a bunch of sites at that same level
where you can find plant fossils and so
we have a bunch of localities here and
then a bunch there and
and a bunch here at the very end of the
Paleolithic urban isotope excursion and
the body of the carbon isotope excursion
here and there not as many but there are
now something like 15 sites within the
body of the excursion and then there a
bunch that are during that recovery
interval as the carbon isotope
composition is returning back to what it
was before and also the climate is
returning to its previous state and then
we have a bunch more localities here so
I just piled them up there about a
hundred localities in this million year
interval and so it gives us you know
like we don't have a perfect record we
wish you know I I would if anyone can
help me fill in that gap that's about a
thirty thousand year long gap right
before the onset of the excursion don't
have any sites there yeah but but we
have we have a record that we actually
you know can sort of feel pretty decent
about using and so I you bring back the
floors you divide them up into
provisional species units and then you
can start to put together a record of
how the flora changed over time and this
is a to a paleontologist this is sort of
like the most basic standard diagram but
I'm going to explain it to you in case
you're not used to looking at these so
this is time again going this way this
that these are the stratigraphic ranges
of different taxa different species
level units and every place where
there's a ball is a locality where it's
actually recorded and I'm making the
assumption that the species was present
in this area between the places where it
actually occurs but of course it's
always possible that that's incorrect
that it went locally extinct and then
came back again and here's again the
body of the carbon isotope excursion
that represents the period when the
climate was the most was the hottest and
the most different from the
around climate State and here's the
recovery interval and you can sort of
divide this up this range chart
stratigraphic range chart up into chunks
of ranges of different types and I'm
going to describe them and I ask you to
notice the the color scheme here of the
boxes so in blue
we've got species that come up close to
the end of the peléan we never see them
again
and those are what I would call possible
extinctions at least Reaper mannan
regional extra patient's of those
species you might wonder why they'd all
come up right to the end that's because
sampling is not as good as as it might
be so you would expect that species that
you don't always sample are going to
sometimes their last occurrence will be
before their actual last occurrence
there's another group of species here in
orange that are have never been detected
in the Paleocene and they've never been
detected in this area after the PTM
they're only found during this period of
warm climate so that's kind of an
interesting that's like you know first
first take on this is these guys are
immigrating into this part of the world
during this period of much warmer
climate and then they're disappearing
again when the climate cools there are a
few taxa that go through that appear to
go through the event and then there's
another group in green here that show up
during the recovery interval or right
after the recovery interval or in some
cases a little bit higher up this again
could be the sampling problem of I see
if I had more sites I might pick up some
of these guys a little bit lower down
but these appear to be immigrants
they're new to the region but they are
showing up during the event they're
showing up after the event so they're
sort of delayed immigration and then
maybe the most interesting group in some
ways are these is are these ranges that
they they they're present you know in
many of these species are present for a
couple of million years down into the
Paleocene then strangely they have no
occurrences during the body of the
carbon isotope excursion they start to
show up again during the recovery period
and then they're found again in the
Eocene so these I would call local extra
patients they are their species that
appear to have gone locally their local
populations have disappeared during the
event they're not present anywhere where
I can find fossils of them and then they
they come back again after the event so
this results in if you just sort of try
to create the broadest scale like would
you can you tell the difference between
a PTM flora and a flora from before or
after the answer is it's it's really
obvious this is a and non-metric
multidimensional scaling just a way of
putting in a sites by species matrix and
then reducing the dimensionality of the
data set to express on two axes the the
differences in in floral composition and
you can see that the the sites that we
have from the body of the excursion have
a composition as reflected on this
diagram that is really different from
both the Eocene and the paleo scene the
Paleocene and Eocene are more similar
really to one another than either is to
these forests from the body of the PTM
and these red
arrows or orange arrows are pointing to
Flora's that occur during the during the
recovery interval so the body of the
excursion is turns out to be radically
different the recovery interval is
actually much more like the Flora's from
from either before or after the event
and there's a lot of overlap between
Eocene and Paleocene I've also on this
diagram coded each site by the local
environment so we get a certain amount
of specificity of different plant
species showing up in different
depositional environments on the
floodplain so we find plant fossils very
commonly in small lenses of mud that
have filled in channels so the channel
abandons and leaves behind mud with
plant fossils in it and that's what we
collect but in other places we might
find a layer that goes a long ways
laterally that that shows us we're
collecting you know in a in a swamp in a
back and a back swamp in a floovio
floodplain and it's a different
environment so we find slightly
different species in in that kind of
environment so I've coded these and the
reason I was interested in doing that
was just to reassure myself that the we
weren't seeing some kind of switch in
the environments that would cause the
Flora's to look different and so we
wouldn't really be seeing a response to
climate change would just be seeing that
response to some sort of change in the
habitat mosaic on the floodplain and the
red circles are the are that's the
abandoned Channel Oxbow channel
environment and you can see that there
are a fair number of those circle
symbols in the Paleocene and Eocene and
they don't have a flora anything like
these aliasing Eocene thermal maximum
flora so I feel reassured that the it's
we're not just seeing some sort of shift
in what's being preserved
the first thing that might you might it
might occur to you to do is to if you're
aware that there are correlations
between leaf size and shape and climate
and so we're able to take those fossil
leaf taxa and and do basically
essentially a characterization of their
sizes and shapes in this case I'm just
going to show you a one slide of results
but this is just to give you a sense of
the characters that are being looked at
leaf area the number of teeth the ratio
of the number of teeth to the internal
perimeter of the leaf the shape factor
which has to do with the circularity of
the leaf the perimeter ratio and the
ferret diameter so these are features
that have some climatic significance but
I'm not really going to use them that
way they've been this is a series of
modern sites this is work by Dan peppy
and others we're looking at at living
Flora's across a big range of vegetation
types you're able to characterize them
according to those physique to those
leaf size and shape measurements and if
you do an ordination analysis of that
you can then place those those different
vegetation types in a kind of
physiognomic space so this is the this
is a space defined by the leaf size and
shape variables and you can see that
there's a bubble here for a seasonally
dry tropical forest there's one here for
temperate rainforests and the Paleo
scene Flores and also this is true of
the early Eocene one's fit in this sort
of wet temperate rain forest part of
this leaf physiognomic space so this has
got nothing to do with the taxonomic
composition of the flora it's just about
the sizes and shapes of the leaves and
the the best site we have from the PTM
where we're able to make these digital
measurements
fits in the in the seasonally dry
tropical forest part of the of the
diagram so this suggests that we're I
think we're seeing a major change in
vegetation type as well as a turnover in
species composition so just to go back
to this for a second I'm just going to
now show you some of the taxa because
it's always nice to look at a few plant
fossils and and think about what they
might be but I'm gonna the there's going
to be a color code here the blue the
orange for the immigrants the green for
the delayed immigrants and the purple
for the extra baited ones so here are a
couple of things that we think Oh
extinct they're both this is an extinct
genus that called browny asiyraytah this
is de Vidya which is an extant genus
they're both in cornelisz so a clade
that has a lot of diversity and in
temperate latitudes today and they both
go extinct then they're just to take a
look at some of the things that that are
locally extirpated so again they're
there in that paleo scene and they're in
the Eocene but we have yet to find them
during the body of the carbon isotope
excursion and we have a couple of
different types of plot and ACCE
this is an extinct genus this one
actually is also extinct this is a
trifoliate platano it's something that
is a bit weird by by modern day
standards but this is a very these are
both very common long ranging species we
have various a couple of common things
that are in the in the betcha lacey ii
again probably extinct general but
pretty closely allied with quite
recognisably betcha lacey this is
something called fig obso filum which is
probably in the fed a sea although even
that's uncertain and this is source it
if a lacey so Katsura tree we have
something that is essentially identical
to extant Metasequoia dawn redwood
something almost
to modern ginkgo and then we there are
members of the lore AC which are
probably you know which is a family
obviously with a lot of a lot of
tropical and sub-tropical
lineages in it as well as some temperate
so it's not all warm temperate lineages
that go extinct or that dope that are
locally extirpated during the event the
the delayed immigrants are also largely
have a sort of temperate deciduous or
temperate forest look to them this is
something in the Tilley AC II this is
all naseeha
pistol it inflorescences of this that
that make it clear that it is honest we
have like odium and this is in the jus
gland AC and very similar to platic
hairy although there's some dispute
about whether it's actually in the genus
Plateau carrier or something very close
to it so these are these species that
come in after the event is over but have
not been seen in the paleo scene are
also temperate deciduous species the the
PETM
only plants the immigrants that are
there for that brief geologically brief
two hundred thousand year period are
really very different at a high
taxonomic level so fabaceae are really
abundant and also quite diverse there
one two three four five different types
of asia's foliage on this slide and
there are a couple more that aren't here
there are at least three different kinds
of fruits to fabaceae so we really have
a lot of diversity and i'm going to just
show you oh there's also this is an
extinct genus called land ania that was
named by steve manchester in this
Hermanson oh gosh perilously close to 20
years ago the foliage of that is
something that was even
going back even farther was called
Sorella
so it's probably you know whether this
is actually even in melee AC he is
uncertain but it's it has nice pinnately
compound leaves that we have and we have
also the flowers and and where we don't
have the flowers we do have the fruits
from these same PTM deposits it's
described from southern Wyoming in a
later period of very warm climate this
is something that looks very much like
the extant genus gyro carpus we have
fruits with these very long wings on
them too two big wings that come up from
the fruit body there are resin glands
that are hard to see in this photograph
but they're there and also in the leaves
these very interesting sort of
irregularly lobate leaves and if you
look at extant chiraq harpus americana
which is actually has a pan tropical
distribution that's kind of odd but it
is it is pan tropically distributed and
it likes dry tropical forests so and the
this is you know one of those cases
where the fossil even though it's 56
million years old really looks a lot
like the modern look there are several
living species in gyro carpus and it's
it is remarkably similar to those this
is one of the Feb ASIS leaf types that
we have we don't know which which fruit
this goes with but we have some really
nice specimens and this particular leaf
type has an extremely distinctive the
national feature which is it it has a
marginal a very thick marginal vein
that's on one side of the leaflet it's
actually the basal side of the leaflet
you can see it in the specimens that are
preserved in attachment and on the
apical side of the same leaflet you get
sort of
place where the places where the margin
is drawn in along the secondary veins
and then there's this peculiar splitting
of that marginal vein so that it
connects in two places to the primary of
the leaflet and that's that turns out to
be a very unusual feature and it shows
up in the extant genus copay affero
which they're a bunch of species of in
the new world tropics and it also turns
out that it's a it's a genus that seems
to like dry tropical for us so we had
the physiognomic data that suggested
that this was a dry tropical forest and
now we have just a couple of of taxa
that are these immigrants during the PTM
and they also as far as we're able to
tell have living relatives in dry
tropical forests and this is just a
family level attempt to show you how
different that the PTM is and I think
I'm actually going to sort of go through
this one quickly because it's not
terrifically important to my point
except just to say that this is this
gives you out of all possible
occurrences what proportion are seen
during the Paleocene in blue the Eocene
in green the post PTM Eocene or the PTM
in orange and there's some interesting
patterns here for instance so betcha
lacey is very it's hers in many places
before before the PTM in none during the
PTM and in lots of in a fairly high
proportion of the places in the Eocene
and fabaceae as exactly the opposite
pattern so we've reconstructed with the
aid of an artist what we think that
transition might have looked like and
here's a sort of latest
aliasing relative
we wet warm but wet climate with things
like ginkgos and metasequoia x' the
paleocene-eocene thermal maximum the
body of that event with this dry
tropical forest here shown in the dry
season so you can really tell the
difference and then in the earliest you
see in a return to a similar kind of
vegetation to what we had before so what
what I think is going on in just sort of
the bio Geographic view of what of what
we're seeing is so we're sitting and
detecting all this in one spot and of
course we'd love to have many other
places around the planet when where we
could record the same event in other
Flores but we don't have them yet but I
think what is likely to be going on is
that during the event as the event sets
on we're basically getting as the
climate shifts to much warmer and in the
case of this continental interior also
probably much more seasonally dry a
precipitation regime we are seeing
species that that had been occurring
much farther south and then in the image
at the edge of the tropics perhaps
moving their ranges northward we're
getting the local extrication of
populations of warm temperate lineages
which are probably then being left as
relics either at high latitudes or in
montane areas at mid latitudes during
the during the warm part of the event
during the body of the carbon isotope
excursion there's almost certainly some
interchange and this is seen in the
fauna as well as in the flora across
these whole arctic regions so you're
you're getting mixing of phonons and
Flora's between Asia and Europe and
North America in spite of the fact that
it they look like we have we have big
water gaps here they must not be
preventing the migration or
extension of ranges across the high
latitudes and then as you go into the
recovery and the cooling of climate back
into the Eocene basically some of those
species that had gotten across between
continents are moving back into the
temperate regions and that's where we're
getting these delayed immigrants the the
the temperate lineages that are showing
up in North America for the first time
in the Eocene are had been derived from
either high latitude areas or from other
continents than North America so let me
see I have this that's about it isn't it
I should be I should be wrapping up and
I sort of just did and I'm looking for a
hundred to tell me whether he's like
like should I go for I can I can do a
very fast version of if but I you know I
know people have classes and things like
that
five minutes okay I will I will give you
the very shortest of all ready so the
the the I've talked about climate change
obviously there's another component this
is like what's the co2 concentration in
the atmosphere this is a Geoscience
question and it was and probably
everybody's aware of this but you know
this spontaneous over a hundred years
ago said and this is a quote from his
paper doubling of the percentage of co2
in the air would raise the surface
temperature of the earth by four degrees
Celsius and this is the IPCC report from
2014 saying the likely range of
equilibrium climate sensitivity that's
the same number is one and a half to
four and a half degrees C so sort of
feel like how much progress have we made
in a hundred years in knowing what the
relationship is between the amount of
co2 in the atmosphere and the
temperature of the planet it would
appear not much so one of the problems
is knowing is in answering that question
is it takes a long time for the co2 to
warm the atmosphere if you have an event
when the amount of co2
miss fear increased a great deal in a
few thousand years you actually have a
great setup for answering this question
so the PTM is a place where we're trying
to answer the question and we're trying
to do it with using stomata l-- evidence
from fossil ginkgos you all know what
stomata are there's something called
stomata index which is the number of
stomata divided through by the number of
epidermal cells plus number of stomata
we have a may in these same sections
that I've been working in remarkably
well-preserved gingko fossils this is
one of this is a 56 point 1 million year
old gingko fossils there's a whole
plastic bag full of gingko fossilized
gingko cuticle and the preservation of
these is quite good this is the fossil
this is a living gingko biloba and this
is some work that I did with Dana Roy
years ago trying to develop a
calibration for using herbarium sheets
like what's the relationship between
that stomata index number and the amount
of co2 in the atmosphere over the last
couple of hundred years it appeared
there was a very strong relationship
rich Barclay the guy I mentioned at the
beginning came to work with me on a
postdoc and we discovered that the
picture wasn't quite as pretty as as we
had thought it was when we did the work
back in the early part of this
millennium so the relationship is much
Messier these are points way out in this
so this is this is historical data and
these are this is you know a lot more
co2 in the atmosphere
there had been a few experiments done we
applied this we developed basically a
reconstruction of changing co2 right
before the PTM and we have a few
specimens of gingko from the recovery
period and it looks as if there is a
substantial increase from say about
three and a little bit more than
pre-industrial levels like mid-1990
levels of co2 and about a doubling in
the last one
thousand years or 50,000 years prior to
the PTM which is consistent with
observed and observed warming of about
five degrees so that that's very cool
except we had a lot of trouble believing
that because the calibration curve out
here is very poorly constrained by just
a few experiments so a few years ago we
set up this experiment and suddenly I've
been a scientist for 40 years
and I can confess you I have never done
a serious experiment isn't that amazing
I mean I can say that to a bunch of
people who work on living plants like
I've never done an experiment I'm an old
scientist who never did an experiment
and now we're doing an experiment and my
respect for people who do experiments
has gone through there is to complain
about field work but experiments are
really hard so we're we're you know this
like we're we have chambers and the
chambers that blowers and we're exposing
ginkgos to 400 outside 400 in chambers
600 and sparts per million in chambers
800 parts per million in chambers and
thousand parts per million in chamber
and we're met we have like we don't have
armies of grad students at the
Smithsonian so we have armies of
volunteers working on this project and
we have online volunteers and you can
help us with this if you want to count
stomata because there's a site here
where you can count them these are
people in the in the cloud counting
stomata for us and so far we're we're
you know we're it's going to take a few
years we think for the plants to
actually fully adapt physiologically to
the high co2 conditions we're not seeing
a response yet and we're also trying to
make measurements of conductance and
photosynthetic rate and we're also
measuring their carbon isotope
composition because there's some
suggestion that the the amount of
discrimination may be also a possible
proxy for
for co2 so that's the quick version of
that Thanks we did we have no indication
of any c4 plants I mean not in not in
the fossils but also not in the when you
sample floodplain soils for for organic
carbon you know that the composition the
isotopic composition of the organic
matter is always consistent with pure c3
but yeah which is interesting because
during the event well during the event
co2 goes up so maybe that would
disadvantage c4 plants because of your
paper we are and yeah know where we are
we are actually there are 50 leaves on
each tree that are that are marked with
a little tiny twisty twist high type
thing around the petiole before they
obsess and there and and they're labeled
with which branch they're on the
branches are numbered on every tree and
the short shoots are numbered so we have
we know which leaves are not only do we
know whether they're short shoot or long
shoot we know where on the tree they
came from exactly they're all they're
clones and they're all they're all male
trees so we are we're trying to
eliminate some of the sources of
variation but not all of them
so you think that there's well I don't
know why there's not yet a response i-i
think these trees are maybe a metre and
a half two meters tall so it's possible
that they are they have enough stored
starch and III mean I think that they
may take them a little while to to
realize that they're growing I mean they
they obviously have gingko sirs we
everyone knows ginkgos are stupid so
this is but they they are chain and they
appear to be changing their the the
conductivity of the leaves say if you
can measure changes in connectivity so
but there may be some history to the
carbon that's already in the in the plan
that's affecting how quickly it respects
it adjusts its the model Anatomy that's
kind of a made-up thing I mean it could
be that that it could also be that they
don't respond above some level of co2
and that that the entire business of
inferring how much co2 in the atmosphere
is in the atmosphere above 400 parts per
million or something is just balloon
juice
I mean it that could be just wrong I
think that remains to be seen this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at Cornell edu